Shawn Woodford in his first moments of
returning consciousness was not aware
that he was lying in his coffin
he had only adult on utter darkness and
that there was a close heavy quality in
the air he breathed he felt very weak
and had only a dim curiosity as to where
he was and how he had come there he knew
that he was not lying in his bedroom at
home for the darkness there was never so
complete as this home that memory
brought others to John Woodford's dolt
brain and he recalled his wife now and
his son he remembered too that he had
been very ill at home very ill and that
was all that he could remember what was
this place to which he had been brought
why was the darkness so complete and the
silence so unbroken and why was there no
one near him he was a sick man and they
should have given him better care than
this he lay with adult irritation at
this treatment growing in his mind then
he became aware that breathing was
beginning to hurt his lungs that the air
seemed warm and foul why didn't someone
open a window his irritation grew to
such a point that it spurred his muscles
into action he put out his right hand to
reach for a bell or a light button his
hand moved slowly only a few inches to
the side and then was stopped by an
unyielding barrier his fingers feebly
examined it it seemed a solid wall of
wood or metal faced with smooth satin it
extended all along his right side and
when he weakly moved his other arm he
found a similar wall on that side to his
irritation gave way to mystification why
in the world did they put him a sick man
into this narrow place why his shoulders
rubbed against the sides on either side
he would soon know the reason for it he
told himself he raised up to give
utterance to a call that would bring
those in attendance on him to his utter
amazement his head bumped against a
similar silk-lined wall directly above
his face he raised his arms in the
darkness and discovered with growing
astonishment that this wall our ceiling
extended above him from head to foot
like those on either side he lay upon a
similar silk padded surface why in the
name of all that was holy had they put
him into a silk lined box like this
Woodford's brain was puzzling this when
a minor irritation made itself felt his
collar was hurting him it was a high
stiff collar and it was pressing into
the flesh of his neck but this again was
a mystery that he should be wearing a
stiff collar why had they dressed a sick
man in formal clothes and put him into
this box
suddenly John Woodford shrieked and the
echoes of his scream reverberating
around his ears like hideous demonic
laughter he suddenly knew the answer to
it all he was not a sick man anymore at
all he was a dead man or at least they
had thought him dead and had put him
into this coffin and closed it down
he was buried alive the fears of his
lifetime had come true his secret dark
forebodings were hideously realized from
earliest childhood he had feared this
very horror for he had known himself
subject to cataleptic sleeps hardly to
be distinguished from death he had had
nightmares of premature burial even
after the proneness to the cataleptic
conditions seemed to have left him his
fears had clung to him he had never told
his wife or son of his fears but they
had persisted they had inspired him to
exact a promise that he would not be
embalmed when buried and would be
interred in this private vault instead
of in the earth he had thought that in
case he were not really dead these
provisions might save his life but now
he realized that they only laid him open
to the horrible fate he had dreaded he
knew with terrible certainty that he now
lay in his coffin in the stone vault in
the quiet Cemetery his screams could not
be heard outside the vault probably not
even outside the coffin as long as he
had lain in cataleptic sleep he had not
breathed but now that he was awake and
breathing the air in the coffin was
rapidly being exhausted and he was
doomed to perish of suffocation
John Woodford went temporarily mad he
screamed with fear choked throat and as
he shrieks he clawed with hands and feet
at the unyielding satin covered surfaces
around and above him he beat upward as
best as he could upon the coffins lid
with his clenched fists but the heavy
fastenings held firm
he yelled until his throat was too
swollen to give utterance to further
sound he clawed at the top until he
broke his nails against the metal behind
the silk padding he raised his head and
beat against the top with it until he
fell back half stunned he lay exhausted
for moments unable to make further
efforts in his brain marched a hideous
pageant of Horrors the air seemed much
closer and hotter now seemed to burn his
lungs with each breath he inhaled with a
sudden return of his frenzy he shrieked
and shrieked again this would not do he
was in a horrible situation but he must
do the best he could not to give way to
the horror he had not many minutes left
and he must use them in the most
rational way possible to try to escape
his terrible prison with this resolution
a little calm came to him and he began
to test his powers of movement he
clenched his fists again and hammered
upward but this did no good his arms
were jammed so close against his body by
the coffins narrowness that he could not
strike a strong blow nor had any
leverage to push strongly upward what
about his feet feverishly he tried them
but found his kicks upward even less
powerful he thought of punching up his
knees and thus bursting up the lid but
found that he could not raise his knees
high enough and that when he pressed
upward with them against the lid his
feet simply slid away on the smooth silk
of the coffins bottom now the breasts he
drew seared his lungs and nostrils and
his brains seemed to be on fire he knew
his strength is waning and that before
long he would lose consciousness he must
do whatever he could swiftly he felt the
soft silk about him and the dreadful
irony of it came home to him he had been
placed so lovingly in this deathtrap he
tried to turn on his side for he thought
now that he might use his shoulders to
heave up against the lid but turning was
not easy in the cramped coffin and had
to be accomplished by a myriad little
hitching movements and infinitely slow
and painful process
John Woodford hitched and squirmed
desperately until he lay on his left
side
he found then that his right shoulder
touched the lid above he braced his left
shoulder on the coffins bottom and
heaved upward with all his strength
there was no results the lid seemed as a
moveable as ever he heaved again despair
fast filling his heart he knew that very
soon he would give way and shriek and
claw there was already a ringing in his
ears he had not many minutes left with
the utter frenzy of despair he heaved
upward again with his shoulder this time
there was a grating sound of something
giving above the sound was like the wild
peal of thousands of bells of hope to
Jean Woodford's ears he heaved quickly
again and again at the lid paying no
attention to the bruising of his
shoulder he pressed upward with every
ounce of his strength
there was another grating sound than a
snap of metal fastenings breaking and as
he shoved upward with convulsive effort
the heavy metal lid swung up and over
and struck the stone wall with a deep
clang a flood of cold air struck him he
struggled up over the coffin side
dropped a few feet to a stone floor and
lay in a huddled mass it was minutes
before he had mastered himself and
summit enough strength to stand up he
stood inside a little vault that held no
coffin but his own it's interior was in
darkness safer a dim shaft of starlight
that came through a tiny window high up
in one wall
John Woodford stumbled to the vaults
heavy iron doors and fumbled at their
lock he had an uncontrollable horror of
this place that had almost been the
scene of his perishing the coffin there
on the shelf with its lid leaning
against the stone wall seemed gaping for
him with his dark cavernous mouth
he worked frantically at the lock what
if he was not able to escape from the
vault but the heavy lock was easily
manipulated on the inside he found he
managed to turn its tumbler and shoot
its bar and then the heavy iron door
swung open
John Woodford stepped eagerly out into
the night he stopped on the vaults
threshold closing the doors behind him
and then looking forth with
inexpressible emotions the cemetery lay
in the Starlight before him as a dim
ghostly city of looming monuments and
vaults little sheets of ice glinted here
and there in the dim light and the air
was biting and it's cold outside the
cemeteries low wall blinked the lights
of the surrounding city Woodford started
eagerly across the cemetery on heating
of the cold somewhere across the lights
of the city was his home his wife and
somewhere his son thinking him dead
mourning him how glad they would be when
he came back to them alive his heart
expanded as he pictured their amazement
and their joy at his return he came to
the low stone wall of the cemetery and
clambered quickly over it it was
apparently well after midnight for the
cars and pedestrians in sight in the
suburban section were few Woodford
hurried along the street he passed
people who looked at him in surprise and
only after some time did he realize the
oddness of his appearance a middle-aged
man clad in a formal suit and lacking
hat and overcoat was an odd person to
meet on a suburban street on a winter
midnight but he paid small attention to
their stares he did turn up the collar
of his frock coat to keep out the cold
but he hardly felt the frigid air and
the emotions that filled him he wanted
to get home to get back to Helen to
witness her stupefaction and daunting
joy when she saw him return from the
dead living a street car came clanging
along and John Woodford stepped quickly
out to board it but almost as quickly
stepped back he had mechanically thrust
his hand into his pocket and found it
quite empty that was to be expected of
course they didn't put money in a dead
man's clothes no matter he would soon be
there on foot as he reached the section
in which his home was located he glanced
in a store window in passing and saw on
a tear sheet calendar a big black date
that made him
it was a date ten days later than the
one he last remembered he had been
buried in the vault for more than a week
more than a week in that coffin it
seemed incredible terrible but that did
not matter now he told himself it would
only make the joy of his wife and son
the greater when they found he was alive
- Woodford himself it seemed as though
he were returning from a journey rather
than from the dead returned from the
dead as he hastened along the tree
boarded street on which his home was
located he almost laughed aloud as he
thought of how amazed some of his
friends would be when they met him they
would think him a ghost or a walking
corpse would perhaps shrink and terror
from him at first but that thought
brought another he must not walk in on
Helen too abruptly the husband she had
buried ten days ago
must not appear to suddenly or the shock
might easily kill her he must contrive
somehow to soften the shock of his
appearance must make sure that he did
not startle her too much with this
resolve in mind when he reached his big
house set well back from the street
Woodford turned aside through the
grounds instead of approaching the front
entrance
he saw windows lighted in the library of
the house and went toward them he would
see who was there would try to break the
news of his return gently to Helen he
silently climbed onto the terrace
outside the library windows and
approached the tall easements he peered
in through the silken curtains inside he
could clearly see the rooms soft lit
interior cozy with the shelves of his
books and with the lamps and fireplace
Helen his wife sat on a sofa with her
back partly toward the window beside her
sat a man that would fer dreck ignite as
one of his closest friends
Curtis Dawes the sight of Dawes gave
Woodford an idea he would get Dawes
outside in some way and have him break
the news of his return to Helen his
heart was pounding at the sight of his
wife then Curtis Dawes spoke his words
dimly audible to woodford outside the
window happy Helen he was asking so
happy dear she answered turning toward
him
out in the darkness Woodford stared and
perplexed wonder how could she be happy
when she thought her husband dead and
buried
he heard Curtis Dawes speaking again it
was a long time the man was saying those
years that I waited Helen she laid her
hand tenderly on his I know and you
never said a word I respected so your
loyalty to John she looked into the fire
musingly John was a good husband Curt he
really loved me and I never let him
guess that I didn't love him that it was
you his friend that I loved but when he
died I couldn't feel grief I felt regret
for his sake of course but underneath it
was the consciousness that at last you
and I were free to love each other Dawes
his arm went tenderly around her
shoulder darling you don't regret that I
talked you into marrying me right away
you don't care that people may be
talking about us I don't care for
anything but you she told him John was
dead young jack has his own home and
wife and there was no reason in the
world why we should not marry I'm glad
that we did in the darkness outside the
window a stunned two days John Woodford
saw her lift and illuminated face toward
the man's I'm proud to be your wife at
last year no matter what anyone may say
about us he heard woodford ruse lowly
back from the window he paused in the
darkness under the trees his mind shaken
torn so this was his home coming from
the tomb
this was the joy he had anticipated in
Helen when he returned it couldn't be
the truth his ears had deceived him
Helen could not be the wife of Curtis
Dawes yet part of his mind told him
remorselessly that it was true he had
always sensed that Helens feeling for
him was not as strong as his for her but
that she had loved Dawes he had never
dreamed yet now he remembered Dawes his
frequent visits the odd silences between
him and Helen he remembered a thousand
trifles that spoke of the love which
these two had cherished for each other
what was he John Woodford to do walk-in
upon them and tell them they had been
premature and Counting him dead that he
had come back to claim his position in
life and his wife again he couldn't do
it if Helen during those years had
wavered in the least and her loyalty to
him he would have had less compunction
but in the face of those years of silent
uncomplaining life with him he couldn't
now reappear to her and blast her
newfound happiness and blacken her name
Woodford laughed a little bit early he
was then to be a Nina garden from the
tomb a strange role surely yet it was
the only one open to him what was he to
do he couldn't let Helen know now that
he was alive couldn't return to the home
that had been his yet he must go
somewhere where with a sudden leap of
the heart he thought of Jack his son he
could at least go to Jack let his son
know that he was living Jack at least
would be overjoyed to see him and would
keep the fact of his return secret from
his mother
John Woodford with that thought
rekindling a little his numbed feelings
started back through the trees toward
the street where he had approached the
house but minutes before with eager
steps
he stole away now like a thief fearful
of being observed he reached the street
and started across the blocks toward the
cottage of his son few were abroad for
the cold seemed increasing and it was
well past midnight
Woodford mechanically rubbed his
stiffened hands as he hurried along he
came to his son's neat little white
cottage and felt relief as he saw lights
from its lower windows also he had
feared that no one would be up he
crossed the frozen lawn to the lighted
windows intent on seeing if Jack was
there and if he was alone he peered in
as he had done at his own home jack was
sitting at a little desk and his young
wife was perched on the arm of his chair
and was listening as he explained
something to her from a sheet of writing
on the desk
John Woodford pressing his face against
the cold windowpane could hear Jack's
words you see Dorothy we can just make
it by adding our savings to dad's
insurance money Jack was saying Oh Jack
cried Dorothy happily and it's what
you've wanted so long a little business
of your own
Jack nodded it won't be very big to
start with but I'll make it grow all
right this is the chance I've been
hoping
for and I'm sure going to make the most
of it of course he said his face
sobering a little it's too bad about dad
going like that but saying that he did
die the insurance money solves our
problems of getting started now you take
the overhead he said and began unreeling
a string of figures to the intent
Dorothy John Woodford ruse lowly back
from the window he felt more dazed and
bewildered than ever he had forgotten
the insurance he had carried which he
had intended to give Jack his start but
of course he saw now it had been paid
over when he was believed dead he was
not dead but living yet if he let Jack
know that it meant the end of his son's
long-desired opportunity Jack would have
to return the insurance money to the
company wrecking his dreamed of chance
how could he let him know then he John
Woodford had already decided that he
must remain dead to his wife and
therefore to the world he might as well
remain so to his son also it was for the
best
John Woodford melted away from the
cottage into the darkness when he
reached the street he stood in
indecision a freezing wind had begun to
blow and he felt very cold without an
overcoat mechanically turned his
coat-collar closer around his neck he
tried to think what he must do
neither helen nor jack must know that he
was living and that meant no one in the
city must know he must get out of the
town to some other place take up life
under some other name but he would need
help and money to do that
where was he to get them barred as he
was from calling out his wife her son to
whom could he turn for help without
letting his return become generally
known Howard Norris the name came at
once to wood for its lips Norris had
been his employer head of the firm where
Woodford had held a position for many
years Woodford had been one of his
oldest employees
Howard Norris would help him get to a
position somewhere else and would keep
his reappearance secret
he knew where nurses residence was
several miles out in the country but he
couldn't walk that far and he had no
taxi or trolley fare he would have to
telephone Norris Woodford walked back
toward the city central section had bent
against the piercing cold wind he
succeeded in finding an all-night lunch
room whose proprietor allowed him to use
the telephone with cold stiffened
fingers he dialed Nora's number Howard
Nora's sleepy voice soon came over the
wire mr. Norris this is Woodford John
Woodford he said quickly
there was an incredulous exclamation
from Howard Norris you're crazy
John Woodford's been dead and buried for
a couple of weeks no I tell you it's
John Woodford insisted Woodford I'm not
dead at all I miss living as you are if
you'll come into town for me you'll see
for yourself I'm not likely to drive to
town at 2:00 in the morning to look at a
maniac NORs replied acidly whatever your
game is you're wasting your time on me
but you've got to help me
Woodford cried I've got to have money a
chance to get out of the city without
anyone knowing I gave your firm my
services for years and now you've got to
give me help listen to me whoever you
are snapped Norris over the wire I was
bothered long enough with John Woodford
when he was living he was so inefficient
we'd have ticked him out long ago if we
hadn't been sorry for him but now that
he's dead you needn't think you can
bother me and his name goodnight
the receiver clicked in Woodford's
unbelieving ear he stared at the
instrument so that was what they had
really thought of him at the firm there
where he had always thought himself one
of the most highly valued of employees
but there must be someone upon whom he
could call for help someone he could
convince that John Woodford was still
living someone who would be glad to
think that he might be living
what about Willis gran-gran had been his
closest friend next to Curtis Dawes he
had lent money more than once to
woodford in the past and certainly
should be willing to do so now hastily
Woodford called grands number this time
he was more careful in his approach when
he heard the others voice Willis I've
got something to tell you that may sound
incredible but you've got to believe do
you hear he said who is this and what in
the world are you talking about demanded
grand startled voice Willis this is John
Woodford do you hear John Woodford
everyone thinks I'm dead but I'm not and
I've got to see you what cried the
others voice over the telephone why you
must be drunk
I saw Woodford lying in his coffin
myself so I know he's dead I tell you
it's not so I'm not dead Woodford almost
screamed I've got to get some money
though to get away from here and you
must lend it to me
you always lend it to me before and I
need it now worse than I ever did I've
got to get away so that's it said Willis
grin because I used to help Woodford out
you think you can get money from me just
by calling me up and pretending that
you're him why would furred himself was
the biggest pest in the world with his
constant borrowing I felt almost
relieved when he died and now you tried
to make me believe these come back from
the dead to pester me again but he never
died I'm John Woodford really Woodford
protested vainly sorry old Tom returned
Gran's mocking voice next time pick a
living person to impersonate not a dead
one he hung up John Woodford slowly
replaced the receiver and made his way
out into the street the wind was blowing
harder and now was bringing with it
clouds of fine snow that stung against
his face like sand he shivered as he
stumbled along the streets of dark shops
his body freezing as his mind was frozen
there was no one from whom he could get
help he saw his paramount necessity was
still to get out of the city and to do
that he must rely on himself
the icy blasts of the snow Laden wind
penetrated through his thin coat his
hands were shaking with the cold a sign
caught Woodford's eye the illuminated
beacon of a relief lodging house at once
he made his way toward it he could at
least sleep there tonight get started
from the city in the morning the shabby
men dozing inside and chairs looked
queerly at him as he entered so did the
young clerk to whom he made his way I'd
like to stay here tonight he said to the
clerk the clerk stared are you trying to
kid me Woodford shook his head no I'm
penniless and it's cold outside I've got
to stay somewhere the clerk smiled
disdainfully listen fella no one with
duds like yours is that hard up scram
before I call a cop
Woodford looked down at his clothes his
frock coat and stiff white shirt and
gleaming patent leather shoes and he
understood he said desperately to the
clerk but these clothes don't mean
anything I tell you I haven't a penny
will you beat it before I have you
thrown out of here the clerk demanded
Woodford back toward the door he went
outside again into the cold the wind had
increased and more snow was falling the
front of Woodford's coat was soon
covered with it as he pushed along it
came to him as a queer joke that the
splendor of his funeral clothes should
keep him from getting help now he
couldn't even beg a passerby for a dime
who would give to a panhandler in formal
clothes
Woodford felt his body quivering and his
teeth chattering from sheer cold if he
could only get out of the blast of the
icy wind his eyes sought desperately
along the street for a hallway where he
might shelter himself he found a deep
doorway and crouched down inside it out
of the wind and driving snow but hardly
had he done so when a heavy step paused
in front of him and a nightstick wrapped
his feet smartly an authoritative voice
ordered him to get up and go home
woodford did not try to explain to the
policemen that he was not a drunken
citizen fallen by the way he got wearily
to his feet and moved on along the
street
unable to see more than few feet ahead
for the world of snow the snow on which
he was walking penetrated the thin shoes
he wore and his feet were soon even
colder than the rest of his body he
walked with slow dragging steps had been
together our crops beside him had given
way to a low stone wall with a sudden
start he recognized it as the wall of
the cemetery which he had left but hours
before the cemetery containing the vault
from which he had escaped the vault why
hadn't he thought of it before he asked
himself the vaults would be a shelter
from the freezing wind and snow he could
stay there for the night without anyone
objecting he paused feeling for a moment
a little renewal of his former terrors
did he dare go back into that place from
which he had struggled to escape then an
extra strong blast of icy air struck him
and decided him the vault would be
shelter and that was what his frozen
body craved more than anything else
stiffly he climbed over the low stone
wall and made his way through the
cemeteries whitened monuments and vaults
toward the one from which he had escaped
the driving snow covered his tracks
almost as he made them as he trudged
toward the vault
he reached it and tried to tie our doors
anxiously suppose he had locked them
when he left but to his relief they
swung open and he entered and shut them
it was dark inside but he was out of the
wind and snow now and his numbed body
felt a little relief
Woodford sat down in the corner of the
vault it was a shelter for the night at
least it seemed rather ironic that he
had to come back here for shelter but it
was something to be thankful for that he
even had this in the morning when the
storm was over he could leave without
anyone seeing and get out of the city
he sat listening to the wind and snow
shriek outside the stone floor of the
vault was very cold so cold that he felt
his limbs stiffening and cramping and
finally he stood up unsteadily and paced
to and fro in the vault
chafing his arms and hands if you only
had a blanket or even a heavy coat to
lie upon he'd freeze there upon the
stone floor then he turned and his
pacing he bumped into the coffin on the
shelf and a new idea was born in his
mind the coffin why the interior of it
was lined deep with silk and satin
padding it would be warm in the coffin
he could sleep in it far better than on
the cold stone floor but did he dare to
re-enter it again Woodford felt faintly
the former terrors he had experienced
when he had awakened in it but they
meant nothing he told himself he would
not be fastened in this time and his
frozen flesh yearned for the warmth of
the coffins lining slowly carefully he
climbed up and lowered himself into the
coffin and stretched out the silken
padding he sank into had a grateful
warmth he lowered his head upon the soft
little pillow with a sigh of relief this
was better he experienced enormous
luxurious comfort now but after he had
lain for a little while he felt that the
top of his body was still cold where the
cold air came into the open coffins top
that cold air entering kept him from
being completely warm if the lid above
him were just closed to keep out the
cold air
he reached up and got the edge of the
heavy metal lid then let it down upon
himself he was completely in the dark
now inside the closed coffin but he was
warm too for the lid kept out the cold
air and he was getting warmer all the
time as his body warmed up the interior
yes it was far more comfortable with the
lid closed and even warmth now pervaded
his whole being and the air inside the
coffin was still getting warmer and
thicker he felt a little drowsy now as
he breathed that warm air felt
luxuriously sleepy as he lay on the soft
silk it was getting a little harder to
breathe somehow as the air became
thicker he ought really to raise the
coffin lid and let in some fresh air but
it was so warm now and the air outside
was so cold and he was more and more
sleepy something dim and receding and
his fading consciousness told him that
he was on the way to suffocation but
what if he was was his sleep he thought
he was better off in here than back in
the world outside he had been a fool
ever to fight so hard before to get out
of this warm comfortable coffin to get
back to that outside world no it was
better like this the darkness and the
warmth and the sleep that advanced
nobody would ever know that he had
awakened at all that he had been away
from here at all everything would be
just as before just as before and with
that comforting assurance John Woodford
was swept farther and farther down the
dark stream of unconsciousness from
which this time there would be no
returning
[Music]
I awoke abruptly from a horrible dream
and stared wildly about then seeing the
high arched ceiling and the narrow
stained windows of my friend's room a
flood of uneasy revelation coerced over
me and I knew that all of Andrews hopes
had been realized I lay supine in a
large bed the posts of which reared
upward and dizzy perspective while on
vast shelves about the chamber were the
familiar books and antiques I was
accustomed to seeing in that secluded
corner of the crumbling and ancient
mansion which had formed our joint home
for many years on a table by the wall
stood a huge candelabrum of early
workmanship and design and the usual
light window curtains had been replaced
by hangings of sombre black which took
on a faint ghostly luster in the dying
light I recalled forcibly the events
preceding my confinement and seclusion
in this veritable medieval fortress they
were not pleasant and I shuddered anew
when I remembered the couch that had
held me before my tendency of the
present one the couch that everyone
supposed would be my last memory burned
afresh regarding those hideous
circumstances which had compelled me to
choose between a true death and a
hypothetical one with a later
reanimation by therapeutic methods known
only to my comrade marshal Andrews the
whole thing had begun when I returned
from the Orient a year before and
discovered to my utter horror that I had
contracted leprosy while abroad I had
known that I was taking grave chances
and caring for my stricken brother in
the Philippines but no hint of my own
affliction appeared until I returned to
my native land
Andrews himself had made the discovery
and kept it from me as long as possible
but our close acquaintance soon
disclosed the awful truth at once I was
quartered in our ancient abode atop the
crags overlooking crumbling Hampton from
whose musty halls and quaint arched
doorways I was never permitted to go
forth it was a terrible existence with
the yellow shadow hanging constantly
over me yet my friend never faltered in
his faith taking care not to contract
the dread scourge but meanwhile making
life is pleasant and comfortable as
possible
he's widespread though somewhat sinister
fame as a surgeon prevented any
authority from discovering my plight and
shipping me away
it was after nearly a year of the
seclusion late in August that Andrews
decided on a trip to the West Indies to
study native medical methods he said I
was left in care of Venerable Symes the
household factotum so far no outward
signs that the disease had developed and
I enjoyed a tolerable though almost
completely private existence during my
colleagues absence it was during this
time that I read many of the tomes
Andrews had acquired and the course of
his 20 years as a surgeon and learned
why his reputation though locally of the
highest was just a bit shady for the
volumes included any number of fanciful
subjects hardly related to modern
medical knowledge treatises and unnethe
aura tative articles on monstrous
experiments in surgery accounts of the
bizarre effects of glandular
transplantation and rejuvenation and
animals and man alike brochures on
attempted brain transference and a host
of other fanatical speculations not
countenanced by Orthodox physicians it
appeared to that Andrews was an
authority on obscure medicament some of
the few books I waded through
revealing that he had spent much time in
chemistry and in the search for new
drugs which might be used as aids in
surgery looking back at those studies
now I find them hellishly suggestive
when associated with his later
experiments Andrews was gone longer than
I expected
returning early in November almost four
months later and when he did arrive I
was quite anxious to see him since my
condition was at last on the brink of
becoming noticeable I had reached a
point where I must seek absolute privacy
to keep from being discovered but my
anxiety was slight as compared with his
exuberance over a certain new plan he
had hatched while in the Indies a plan
to be carried out with the aid of a
curious drug he had learned of from a
native doctor in Haiti when he explained
that his idea concerned me I became
somewhat alarmed though in my position
there could be little to make my plight
worse I had indeed considered more than
once the Oblivion that would come with a
revolver or a plunge from the roof to
the jagged rocks below
on the day after his arrival in the
seclusion of the dimly lit study he
outlined the whole grisly scheme he had
found in Haiti a drug the formula for
which he would develop later which
induced a state of profound sleep in
anyone taking it a trance so deep that
death was closely counterfeited with all
muscular reflexes even the respiration
and heartbeat completely stilled for the
time being
Andrews had he said seen it demonstrated
on natives many times some of them
remain somnolent for days at a time
holy and mobile and as much like death
as death itself this suspended animation
he explained further would even pass the
closest examination of any medical man
he himself according to all known laws
would have to report as dead a man under
the influence of such a drug he stated
too that the subjects body assumed the
precise appearance of a corpse
even a slight rigor mortis developing in
prolonged cases for some time his
purpose did not seem wholly clear but
when the full import of his words became
apparent I felt weak and nauseated yet
in another way I was relieved for the
thing meant at least partial escape from
my curse and escape from the banishment
and shame of an ordinary death of the
dread leprosy briefly his plan was to
administer strong dose of the drug to me
and call the local authorities who would
immediately pronounced me dead and see
that I was buried within a very short
while he felt assured that with their
careless examination they would fail to
notice my leprosy symptoms which in
truth had hardly appeared only a trifle
over 15 months had passed since I had
caught the disease whereas the
corruption takes seven years to run its
entire course later he said would come
resurrection after my interment in the
family graveyard beside my century
dwelling and barely a quarter mile from
his own ancient pile the appropriate
steps would be taken finally when my
estate was settled and my decease widely
known he would secretly open the tomb
and bring me to his own abode again
still alive and none the worse for my
adventure it seemed a ghastly and daring
plan but to me it offered the only hope
for even a partial freedom so I accepted
his proposition but not without a myriad
of misgivings
what if the effect the drugs should wear
off while I was in my tomb what if the
coroner should discover the awful ruse
and fail to enter me these were some of
the hideous doubts which assailed me
before the experiment though death would
have been a release from my curse I
feared it even worse than the yellow
scourge feared it even when I could see
its black wings constantly hovering over
me fortunately I was spared the horror
of viewing my own funeral and burial
rites they must however have gone just
as Andrews had planned even to the
subsequent disinterment for after the
initial dose of the poison from Haiti I
lapsed into a semi paralytic state and
from that to a profound night black
sleep the drug had been administered in
my room and Andrews had told me before
giving it that he would recommend to the
coroner a verdict of heart failure due
to nerve strain of course there was no
embalming Andrews saw to that
and the whole procedure leading up to my
secret transportation from the graveyard
to his crumbling Manor covered a period
of three days having been buried late in
the afternoon of the third day my body
was secured by Andrews that very night
he had replaced the fresh sod just as a
had been when the workmen left old Symes
sworn to secrecy
had held Andrews in his ghoulish task
later I had lain for over a week in my
old familiar bed owing to some
unexpected effect of the drug my whole
body was completely paralyzed so that I
could move my head only slightly all my
senses however were fully alert and by
another week's time I was able to take
nourishment in good quantities Andrews
explained that he had revived my upper
half first and could not account for the
complete bodily paralysis though my
condition seemed to trouble him little
considering the damnably intent interest
he centred upon my reactions and stimuli
from the very beginning many times
during lulls in our conversation I would
catch a strange gleam in his eyes as he
viewed me on the couch a glint of
Victorious exultation which clearly
enough he never voiced aloud though he
seemed to be quite glad that I had run
the gauntlet of death and had come
through alive still there was that
horror I was to meet in less than six
years which added to my desolation in
melancholy during the tedious days in
which I awaited the return of normal
bodily functions
but I would be up and about he assured
me before very long enjoying an
existence few men had ever experienced
the words did not however impress me
with their true and ghastly meaning
until many days later during that awful
siege in bed Andrews and I became
somewhat estranged he no longer treated
me so much like a friend is like an
implement and is skilled and greedy
fingers
I found him possessed of unexpected
traits little examples of baseness and
cruelty apparent even to the hardened
Symes which disturbed me in a most
unusual manner often he would display
extraordinary cruelty to live specimens
in his laboratory for he was constantly
carrying on various hidden projects in
glandular and muscular transplantation
on guinea pigs and rabbits he had also
been employing his newly discovered
sleeping potion and curious experiments
with suspended animation but of these
things he told me very little though old
signs often let slip chance comments
which shed some light on the proceedings
I was not certain how much the old
servant knew but he had surely learned a
considerable amount being a constant
companion to both Andrews and myself
with the passage of time a slow but
consistent feeling began creeping into
my disabled body and at the reviving
symptoms Andrews took a fanatical
interest in my case he still seemed more
coldly analytical than sympathetic
toward me taking my pulse and heart beat
with more than usual zeal occasionally
in his fevered examinations I saw his
hands tremble slightly an uncommon sight
with so skilled a surgeon but he seemed
oblivious of my scrutiny I was never
allowed even a momentary glimpse of my
full body but with a feeble return of
the sense of touch I was aware of a bulk
and heaviness which at first seemed
awkward and unfamiliar
gradually I regained the use of my hands
and arms and with the passing of the
paralysis came a new and terrible
sensation of physical estrangement my
limbs had difficulty in following the
commands of my mind and every movement
was jerky and uncertain so clumsy were
my hands that I had to become accustomed
to them all over again this must I
thought be due to my disease and the
advance of the contagion in my system
being unaware of how the early symptoms
affected the victim my brother's being a
more advanced case I had no means of
judging and since Andrews shunned the
subject I deemed it better to remain
silent one day I asked Andrews I no
longer consider him a friend if I might
try rising and sitting up in bed at
first he objected strenuously but later
after cautioning me to keep the blanket
swell up around my chin so that I would
not be chilled he permitted it this
seems strange and view of the
comfortable temperature now that late
autumn was slowly turning into winter
the room was always well heated a
growing chill enos at night and
occasional glimpses of a leaden sky
through the window had told me of the
changing season for no calendar was ever
in sight upon the dingy walls with the
gentle help of Symes I was eased to a
sitting position
Andrews coldly watching from the door of
the laboratory and my success a slow
smile spread across his leering features
and he turned to disappear from the
darkened doorway his mood did nothing to
improve my condition old Symes usually
so regular and consistent was now often
late in his duties sometimes leaving me
alone for hours at a time
the terrible sense of alienation was
heightened by my new position it seemed
that the legs and arms inside my gown
were hardly able to follow the summoning
of my mind and it became mentally
exhausting to continue movement for any
length of time my fingers woefully
clumsy were wholly unfamiliar to my
inner sense of touch and I wondered
vaguely if I were to be a curse to the
rest of my days with an awkwardness
induced by my dread malady
it was on the evening following my half
recovery that the dreams began I was
tormented not only at night but during
the day as well
I would awaken screaming horribly from
some frightful nightmare I dared not
think about outside the realm of sleep
these dreams consisted mainly of
ghoulish things graveyards at night
stalking corpses and lost souls amid a
chaos a blinding light and shadow the
terrible reality of divisions disturb me
most of all
it seemed that some inside influence was
inducing the grisly vistas of moonlit
tombstones and endless catacombs of the
Restless Dead I could not place their
source and at the end of the week I was
quite frantic with abominable thoughts
which seemed to obtrude themselves upon
my unwelcome consciousness by that time
a slow plan was forming whereby I might
escape the living hell into which I had
been propelled Andrews cared less and
less about me seeming intent only on my
progress in growth and recovery of
normal muscular reactions I was becoming
everyday more convinced of the nefarious
doing this going on in that laboratory
across the threshold the animal cries
were shocking and rasped hideously on my
overwrought nerves and I was gradually
beginning to think that Andrews had not
saved me from deportation solely for my
own benefit but for some accursed reason
of his own Sciences attention was slowly
becoming slider and slider and I was
convinced that the age servitor had a
hand in the devil tree somewhere
Andrews no longer eyed me as a friend
but as an object of experimentation nor
did I like the way he fingered his
scalpel when he stood in the narrow
doorway and stared at me with crafty
alertness
I had never before seen such a
transformation come over any man his
ordinarily handsome features were now
lined in whisker grown and his eyes
gleamed as if some imp of Satan were
staring from them his cold calculating
gaze made me shudder horribly and gave
me a fresh determination to free myself
from his bondage as soon as possible
I had lost track of time during my dream
orgy and had no way of knowing how fast
the days were passing the curtains were
often drawn in the daytime the room
being lit by waxen cylinders in the
large candelabrum it was a nightmare of
living horror and unreality though
through it all I was gradually becoming
stronger I always gave careful responses
to Andrews inquiries concerning my
returning physical control concealing
the fact that a new life was vibrating
through me with every passing day and
altogether strange sort of strength but
one which I was counting on to serve me
in the coming crisis finally one chilly
evening when the candles had been
extinguished and a pale shaft of
moonlight fell through the dark curtains
upon my bed I determined to rise and
carry out my plan of action there had
been no movement from either of my
captors for several hours and I was
confident that both were asleep and
adjoining bed chambers shifting my
cumbersome weight carefully I rose to a
sitting position and crawled cautiously
out of bed down upon the floor a vertigo
gripped me momentarily and a wave of
weakness flooded my entire being
but finally strength returned and by
clutching at a bedpost I was able to
stand upon my feet for the first time in
many months gradually a new strength
coerced through me and I donned the dark
robe which I had seen hanging on a
nearby chair it was quite long but
served as a cloak over my night dress
again came that feeling of awful
unfamiliarity which I had experienced in
bed that sense of alienation and of
difficulty in making my limbs perform as
they should but there was need for haste
before my feeble strength might give out
as a last precaution and dressing I
slipped some old shoes over my feet but
though I could have sworn they were my
own
they seemed abnormally loose so that I
decided they must belong to the age
signs
seeing no other heavy objects in the
room I seized from the table the huge
candelabrum upon which the moon shone
with a pallid glow and proceeded very
quietly toward the laboratory door my
first steps came jerkily and with much
difficulty in the semi-darkness I was
unable to make my way very rapidly when
I reached the threshold a glance within
revealed my former friend seated in a
large overstuffed chair while beside him
was a smoking stand upon which were
assorted bottles in a glass he reclined
half way in the moonlight through the
large window and his greasy features
were creased in a drunken smirk an open
book lay in his lap one of the hideous
tones from his private library for a
long moment I gloated over the prospect
before me and then stepping forward
suddenly I brought the heavy weapon down
upon his unprotected head the dull
crunch was followed by a spurt of blood
and the fiend crumpled to the floor his
head laid half open I felt no contrition
at taking the man's life in such a
manner in the hideous half visible
specimens of his surgical wizardry
scattered around the room in various
stages of completion and preservation I
felt there was enough evidence to blast
his soul without my aid Andrews had gone
too far and his practices to continue
living and as one of his monstrous
specimens of that I was now hideously
certain it was my duty to exterminate
him Symes I realized would be no such
easy matter indeed only unusual good
fortune had caused me to find Andrews
unconscious when I finally reeled up to
the servants bedchamber door
faint from exhaustion I knew it would
take all my remaining strength to
complete the ordeal the old man's room
was in utmost darkness being on the
north side of the structure but he must
have seen me silhouetted in the doorway
as I came in he screamed hoarsely and I
aimed the candelabrum at him from the
threshold it struck something soft
making a sloughing sound in the darkness
but the screaming continued from that
time on events became hazy and jumbled
together but I remember grappling with
the man and choking the life from him
little by little he jibber to hosts of
awful things before I could lay hands on
him cried and begged for mercy from my
clutching fingers I hardly realized my
own strength in that mad
moment which left Andrews associate in a
condition like his own retreating from
the darkened chamber I stumbled for the
stairway door sagged through it and
somehow reached the landing below no
lamps were burning and my only light was
a filtering of moonbeams coming from the
narrow windows in the hall but I made my
jerky way over the cold damp slabs of
stone reeling from the terrible weakness
of my exertion and reached the front
door after ages of fumbling and crawling
about in the darkness vague memories and
haunting shadows came to taunt me in
that ancient hallway shadows once
friendly and understandable but now
grown alien and unrecognizable so that I
stumbled down the worn steps in a frenzy
of something more than fear for a moment
I stood in the shadow of the giant stone
manor viewing the moonlit trail down
which I must go to reach the home of my
forefathers only a quarter of a mile
distant but the way seemed long and for
a while I despaired of ever traversing
the whole of it at last I grasped a
piece of Deadwood as a cane and set out
down the winding road ahead seemingly
only a few rods away in the moonlight
stood the venerable mansion where my
ancestors had lived and died its turrets
rose spectrally in the shimmering
radiance and the black shadow cast on
the beetling hillside appeared to shift
in a waver as if belonging to a castle
of unreal substance there stood the
monument of half a century a haven for
all my family old and young which I had
deserted many years ago to live with the
fanatical Andrews it stood empty on that
fateful night and I hope that it may
always remain so in some manner I
reached the age at place though I do not
remember the last half of the journey at
all it was enough to be near the family
cemetery among whose moss covered in
crumbling stones I would seek the
Oblivion I had desired as I approached
the moonlit spot the old familiarity so
absent during my abnormal existence
return to plague me in a wholly
unexpected way I drew close to my own
tombstone and the feeling of homecoming
grew stronger with it came a fresh flood
of that awful sense of alienation and
disembodiment which I knew so well
I was satisfied that the end was drawing
near nor did I stop to analyze emotions
till a little later when the full horror
of my position burst upon me intuitively
I knew my own tombstone for the grass
had scarcely begun to grow between the
pieces of sod with feverish haste I
began clawing at the mound and scraping
the wet earth from the hole left by the
removal of the grass and roots how long
I worked in the nitrous soil before my
fingers struck the coffin lid I can
never say but sweat was pouring from me
and my nails were but useless bleeding
hooks at last I threw out the last bit
of loose earth and with trembling
fingers tugged on the heavy lid it gave
a trifle and I was prepared to lift it
completely open when a fetid and
nauseous odour assailed my nostrils I
started a wreck horrified had some idiot
place my tombstone on the wrong grave
causing me to unearth another body for
surely there could be no mistaking that
awful stench gradually a hideous
uncertainty came over me and I scrambled
from the hole one look at the newly made
headpiece was enough this was indeed my
own grave but what fool had buried
within it another corpse all at once a
bit of the unspeakable truth propelled
itself upon my brain the odor in spite
of its putrescence seemed somehow
familiar horribly familiar yet I could
not credit my senses with such an idea
reeling and cursing I fell into the
black cavity once more and by the aid of
a hastily lit match lifted the long lid
completely open then the light went out
as if extinguished by a malignant hand
and I clawed my way out of that a curse
had pit screaming and a frenzy of fear
and loathing when I regained
consciousness I was lying before the
door of my own ancient Manor where I
must have crawled after that hideous
rendezvous in the family cemetery I
realized that Dawn was close at hand and
rose feebly opening the aged portal
before me and entering the place which
had known no footsteps for over a decade
fever was ravaging my weakened body so
that I was hardly able to stand but I
made my way slowly through the musty
dimly lit chambers and staggered into my
own study the study I had deserted so
many years before when the Sun is risen
I shall go to the ancient well beneath
the old willow tree by the cemetery and
cast my deformed self into it no other
man shall ever view this blasphemy which
is survived life longer than it should
have I do not know what people will say
when they see my disordered grave but
this will not trouble me if I can find
oblivion from that which I beheld amidst
the crumbling mosque rusted stones at
the hideous place I now know why andrews
was so secretive in his actions so
damnably gloating in his attitude toward
me after my artificial death he had
meant me for a specimen all the time a
specimen of his greatest feat of surgery
his masterpiece of unclean witchery an
example of perverted artistry for him
alone to see where Andrews obtained that
other with which I lay occur sit in his
moldering mansion I shall probably never
know but I am afraid that it was brought
from Haiti along with his fiendish
medicine at least these long hairy arms
and horrible short legs are alien to me
alien to all natural insane laws of
mankind the thought that I shall be
tortured with that other during the rest
of my brief existence is another hell
now I can but wish for that which once
was mine that which every man blessed of
God ought to have at death that which I
saw in that awful moment in the ancient
burial ground when I raised the lid on
my coffin my own shrunken decayed and
headless body